all lesson you are going to understand
the concept of unsupervised learning by
the end of this lesson you will be able
to explain the mechanism of unsupervised
learning use different clustering
techniques in Python overview
unsupervised learning is a machine
learning technique used to train the
machine learning algorithm using data
that is either unclassified or unlabeled
and allows the algorithm to act on that
data without guidance unlabeled data is
a designation for pieces of data that
have not been tagged with labels
identified by characteristics properties
or classifications so the flow of
unsupervised learning starts with
training data that has no labels and
depends on the feature vector the
machine learning model defines the
predictive model this is tested with an
individual subset of data with its own
feature vector here the predictive model
defines the likelihood or cluster ID or
a better representation of unlabeled
data let's look at the difference
between unsupervised and supervised
learning supervised the learning
technique deals with labelled data where
the output data patterns are known to
the system unsupervised a learning works
with unlabeled data in which the output
is just based on the collection of
perceptions supervised to learning
method is less complex the unsupervised
learning method is more complex
supervised learning conducts offline
analysis unsupervised learning performs
real-time analysis the outcome of the
supervised learning technique is
comparatively more accurate and reliable
unsupervised learning generates
moderately acute but reliable results
while classification and regression are
the types of problem solved under the
supervised learning method unsupervised
learning includes clustering and
associative rule mining problems
example and application of unsupervised
learning let's understand unsupervised
learning through an example consider a
scenario where a child had no learning
phase and is shown images without the
labels now if the child is asked to
identify if any range is a bird or an
animal he will lack the information that
can help him do so the best he can do is
come up with the following groups based
on common patterns wings and legs for
example this explains how unsupervised
learning works we show a lot of data to
our algorithm and ask it to find
patterns in the data by itself let's
look at the application of unsupervised
learning unsupervised learning can be
used for anomaly detection as well as
clustering to understand clustering
let's look at a simple real-life example
a mother asks her two children to
arrange the pieces of playing blocks the
children come up with two different
groups as shown with different
similarities in the blocks this is
clustering each of our children came up
with a different type of grouping one
child grouped them based on the shape
whereas the other group to them based on
the color there is no right or wrong way
then how can you pick one set of
clusters over the others this will
depend on the similarity measure used by
the mother in this case the arrangement
of child one is better than child two if
the similarity measure chosen by the
mother was that blocks should have the
same shape however the arrangement by
child two is better if the similarity
measure chosen by the mother was that
blocks should have the same color
therefore defining the similarity
measure is important when performing
clustering there may be different ways
in which data can be arranged in
different groups based on size shape
color texture and other complex features
anomaly detection is a clustering
technique used to identify unusual
patterns that do not conform to expected
behavior anomaly detection has many
applications in business such as
intrusion detection
system health monitoring and fraud
detection clustering the method of
grouping similar entities together is
called clustering the goal of this
unsupervised machine learning method is
to seek out similarities within the data
points and to cluster similar data
points together need for clustering
let's look at the need for clustering
grouping similar entities together helps
to merge the attributes of different
clusters in other words this gives us
insight into underlying patterns of
different groups there are a lot of
applications of grouping unlabeled data
for example in order to maximize the
revenue you can identify different
groups or clusters of customers and
market to each group in a different way
another example is grouping books
together that belong to similar topics
clustering is needed to determine the
intrinsic grouping in a set of unlabeled
data organized data into clusters that
show internal structure of the data
partition the data points understand and
extract value from large sets of
structured and unstructured data types
of clustering there are two types of
clustering hierarchical clustering and
partitioning clustering hierarchical
clustering can be agglomerative and
divisive whereas partitioning clustering
can be k-means and fuzzy c means a
distinction among different types of
clustering is whether the set of
clusters is nested or unnecessary is
just a division of the set of data
objects into non overlapping sets or
clusters such that every data object is
in just one subset a hierarchical
clustering is a tree structure that has
a set of nested clusters hierarchical
clustering the output of hierarchical
clustering is a hierarchy how does the
hierarchical clustering form a hierarchy
assume you are going to create a three
layer hierarchy from six different data
nodes so first combine a and B based on
similarity and also combine D and E
based on similar
combination of a and B is combined with
C in the similar way combination of D
and E is combined with F now combine C
and F inside one cluster when you look
at the final tree it contains all
clusters combined into a single cluster
let's understand the working of
hierarchical clustering it works in four
steps step 1 assign each item to its own
cluster such that if you have n number
of items you will have n number of
clusters step 2 merge two clusters into
a single cluster by finding the closest
pair of clusters now you will have one
cluster less step 3 compute distances
between the new cluster and all old
clusters step 4 repeat steps 2 and 3
until all items are clustered into a
single cluster of size n let's
understand the distance measure in
hierarchical clustering let's look at
the different kinds of linkage in
clustering complete linkage clustering
it finds the maximum distance between
points belonging to two different
clusters single linkage clustering it
finds the minimum possible distance
between points belonging to two
different clusters mean linkage
clustering it finds all possible
pairwise distances for points belonging
to two different clusters and then
calculates the average centroid linkage
clustering it finds the centroid of each
cluster and calculates the distance
between them what is dendrogram it is a
tree diagram frequently used to
illustrate the arrangement of the
clusters produced by hierarchical
clustering it shows the hierarchical
relationship between objects it is most
commonly created as an output of
hierarchical clustering the main use of
a dendrogram is to work out the best way
to allocate objects to clusters the
dendogram also shows the hierarchical
clustering of five observations and the
relationship between each of them
hierarchical clustering example let's
understand hierarchical clustering
through an example in the given exam
imple hierarchical clustering is used to
find the distances between the different
cities in kilometers the following
matrix traces a hierarchical clustering
of distances in miles between different
cities the method of clustering is
single link here as you can see from the
given distance matrix the nearest pair
of objects is tio and mi mi and tio are
merged into a single cluster called mi
tío as mi column has lower values than
tio column mi tío consists of mi column
values mi tío column has one index with
0 value this is because there is no
distance between cluster mi tío and mi
tío to get a new distance matrix we
compute the distance from this new
cluster to all other clusters now the
nearest pair of objects is na + RM these
are combined into a single cluster
called Na RM to get a new distance
matrix we compute the distance from this
new cluster to all other clusters in the
similar way the nearest pair of objects
is BA + na RM these are combined into a
single cluster called ba na RM to get a
new distance matrix we compute the
distance from the new cluster to all
other clusters similarly now the nearest
pair of objects is ba na RM and fi these
combined into a single cluster called ba
na RM fi to get a new distance matrix we
compute the distance from this new
cluster to all other clusters finally we
merge the last two clusters this process
is summarized by the clustering diagram
on the right and the final distance
matrix on the left
demo clustering animals problem scenario
consider the data set zu dot data and
look at the information provided in the
first five rows the first column denotes
the animal name and the last one
specifies the high level class for the
corresponding animal
you are supposed to find a solution to
the following questions one identify the
unique number of high level classes to
perform agglomerative clustering using
the 16 intermediate features 3 compute
the mean squared error by comparing the
actual high level class and the
predicted high level class in a nutshell
you just have to perform agglomerative
clustering with the appropriate MSE
value let's import the required
libraries and the data set
you
since we have now loaded the data set we
will extract some basic information from
it as our first step with the info
command it is clear that the data set
has 18 columns in total and 101 entries
also there are no null values let us now
proceed towards the first question which
is extracting the unique number of
high-level classes most probably the
unique function from numpy will help
you
we can plot the unique number of labels
obtained using the mat plot Lib library
you
create a figure and a set of subplots
you
from the plot it can be seen that we
have seven unique class labels now since
we are about to group animals based on
their features it's clear and quite
predictive that clustering should be
performed
let's now extract the features leaving
the labels column and store them in
another data frame safe features
you
import the necessary modules for
performing clustering
you
specify the number of clusters is 7 note
that here we are specifying the total
number of clusters as 7 because there
are 7 unique class labels
also specify the linkage method as
average and the similarity method as
cosine
fit the agglomerative clustering model
over the feature variable defined
earlier
let us extract the labels predicted by
our model against the features
we can see that we have predicted labels
against all of our 101 animals although
we have seven labels but it is numbered
as six so in this case we can subtract
one from our original label column such
that it matches the predicted numbers
now let us move ahead and predict the
accuracy of our model considering the
predicting parameter as mean squared
error
now evaluate the absolute error by
applying square root operation on the
mean squared error
print the resultant error
the root mean squared error we got is
two point four three approximately which
is quite acceptable
now that we have clustered the animals
let's quickly recap the steps we have
covered import libraries and the data
set check for missing values identify
unique labels and plot them extract
features necessary for clustering within
a single variable fit agglomerative
clustering model on the feature data
predict labels for each animal print the
rmse of the model K means clustering
let's look at the steps involved in
k-means clustering k-means is an
iterative clustering algorithm whose
goal is to find local Maxima in each
iteration this algorithm works in these
four steps specify the desired number of
clusters k randomly assign each data
point to a cluster compute cluster
centroids reassign each point to the
closest cluster centroid and recompute
cluster centroids in order to check if
the convergence criterion is met
consider the dots give
the diagram as the data points first
k-means randomly chooses k examples data
points from the data set the three
colored points as initial centroids this
is because it does not know yet where
the center of each cluster is a centroid
is the center of a cluster assigned data
points to the nearest centroid then all
the data points that are the nearest to
a centroid will create a cluster as you
can see there are three centroids as red
blue and purple and all the data points
of the same color is one cluster so in
total we have three clusters now now we
have new clusters that need centers a
centroids new value is going to be the
mean of all the examples in a cluster
centers are moving because a centroid
will have the value of the mean of all
the data points in a cluster will keep
repeating steps two and three until the
k-means algorithm is converged that is
until the centroids stop moving to mole
number of clusters determining the
optimal number of clusters in a data set
is a fundamental issue in partitioning
clustering such as k-means clustering
this requires the user to specify the
number of clusters k to be generated if
you plot K against SSE you will see that
the error decreases as K increases this
is because their size decreases and
hence distortion is also smaller the
basic idea behind partitioning methods
such as k-means clustering is to define
clusters such that the total width in
cluster sum of square WS s or the total
intra cluster variation is minimized the
elbow method looks at the total WS s as
a function of the number of clusters one
should choose a number of clusters so
that adding another cluster doesn't
significantly improve the total WS s it
works in the following way
compute clustering algorithm for
different values of K for instance by
varying K from 1 to 20 clusters
calculate the total within clusters
of square WS s for each K value
according to the number of clusters K
plot the curve of WS s the location of
bend in the plot is generally considered
as an indicator of the appropriate
number of clusters demo cluster based
incentivization problem scenario lathy
and power is the largest producer of
electric vehicle evey achill batteries
they provide batteries on rent to e
vehicle drivers drivers rent a battery
typically for a day and they are after
replacing it with a charged battery from
the company lithium Power has a variable
pricing model based on the drivers
driving history battery life depends on
factors such as over speeding distance
driven per day etc you are supposed to
create a cluster model where drivers can
be grouped together based on the driving
data and a group the data points so that
drivers will be incentivized based on
the cluster let's import the libraries
numpy and pandas
import visualization libraries namely
mat plot lib and Seaborn
you
import the warning module the warning
module was introduced in pep 230 as a
way to warn programmers about changes in
language or library features in
anticipation of backwards incompatible
changes coming with python 3.0
import met plot lib library for
visualization and an instance of RC
params for handling default met plot lib
values
you
please note for the sake of simplicity
we will take only two features mean
distance driven per day and the mean
percentage of times a driver drove
higher than 5 miles per hour over the
speed limit let us go through each of
the columns first and understand them
the ID column represents the unique ID
of the driver the mean underscore dist
underscored a column represents the mean
distance driven by driver per day and
the mean underscore / underscore speed
underscore purse represents the mean
percentage of the times a driver drove
higher than 5 miles per hour over the
speed limit let's start with using
pandas to read driver data dot CSV as a
data frame called DF
we will now use the info command to
check the number of columns in total and
entries also this will let us know if we
have any missing values in addition to
it we will use the describe function
here to check the count mean and median
values for each column now we will
import k-means from SK learned doctor
and run the algorithm with k equals 2
which is the minimum number of clusters
that can exist in a data set
also let us create an instance of the
k-means model with two clusters such
that it becomes easier to call the same
later
please note that we have dropped the ID
column as it doesn't have any reference
in forming clusters let's now fit the
model to the data
the algorithm is now fitted on our data
and you can claim that it has created
the clusters let us now use some
commands to get some information on
these clusters we will use the command
cluster centers from k-means to
determine the cluster center vectors use
the labels underscore command along with
print to display the labels also we can
go for the lengths of those labels
now let us check how many unique drivers
are there in the first and second
cluster
you
we will set the theme as white grid as
it is better suited to plots with heavy
data elements
plot the clusters using the LM plot
function from the Seaborn library such
that we have a mean underscore dist
underscored a feature on x-axis and mean
underscore over underscore speed purse
on y-axis
you
we can clearly see from the graph
plotted that there are two clusters one
centered around 50 mean distance delay
and the other around 175 also we can see
that there are more drivers in the
cluster with the delay centered at 175
since k-means clustering gives optimum
results who in iterated multiple times
let's try out the same with increasing
the number of clusters say for
you
print the cluster centers with four
clusters and track the four unique
labels along with their frequency of
occurrence
zip the unique number of cluster and
their frequency counts within a
dictionary
we can clearly see the difference now in
cluster centers also here we have a
distribution of data points in each
cluster
let's now plot the same
you
such that we have mean underscore dist
underscored a feature on x-axis
you
and mean underscore over underscore
speed purse on the y-axis
from the four cluster plot we can see
that it's denser compared to the two
cluster plot and hence more optimal
now that we have clustered the data with
the k-means let's quickly recap the
steps we have covered import libraries
and the data set fit the k-means model
on the data set evaluate cluster centers
and labels plot the clusters to see the
distribution of data points iterate the
same by changing the number of clusters
to four again evaluate the cluster
centers plot the clusters to see the
distribution of data points draw
inference out of both plots this brings
us to the end of unsupervised learning
you are now able to explain the
mechanism of unsupervised learning use
different clustering techniques in
python hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here